my name is ren here's our intro already
it's unprofessional intro
all right what's up guys she can't be
here because his dog fell down the
stairs and he had to go to the vet
oh i'm i'm actually like really
heartbroken
everybody pray for bones bones it's a
it's a 15 year old dog yeah she's 15.
she was she's a tiny little like
chihuahua
poodle mix jake's wife wendy found her
in a garbage can oh my goodness
wait like like 15 years ago okay
wow um wow it was a little puppy just in
a garbage can someone threw the dog away
and they rescued her
and they've had her ever since so i was
like really really sad garbage dog
turned to family dog
yeah apparently she fell down some
stairs and broke her hip and as a 15
year old dog that's not exactly
something that you
come back from really is there like
internal bleeding associated with that
well it's just like
it's more of like as if you're what is
your mic
towards you is this your first podcast
with my mic it's this the mic is right
here okay
not with these bad boys all right this
is also the first ever mask
cast mass cast baby 2021 we're always
wearing mess
hopefully hopefully one in five of us
one of us probably has corrections no
it's not one in five it's one in five
people getting tested
yeah one or five people getting tested i
mean we're getting tested
all the time so i mean it's like four of
us so it's
should be pitched he's all the way over
there and there are technically five
people in this room when you go standing
on a testing site chances are one of
those five people
when you look around you has it that's
what the stat is yeah
yeah yeah well that sucks
yeah all right we got our covered talk
out of the way yeah yeah it's also like
you know
the holidays we were all you know in
different places with family yada yada
yeah parties bars
precautionary works yeah i made out with
so many strangers
yeah the old coughing circles as we do
that's right
i just went up to people and just open
my mouth and allowed them to cough and
taste yeah
yeah it's great that's great good family
fun do you guys get anything good for
christmas ooh anything good
ooh i got these socks people are always
giving me socks man because my socks are
so disgusting
i didn't know there's a thing about you
i didn't know this was a reputation that
i have discussing socks well now
everybody thinks you have discussing
socks well i do
it's because i just wear them around the
house and the bottom gets really dirty
so i do the same thing
yeah mm-hmm you know peter 38 didn't
have to see that gross
oh yeah that's not too bad that's a
weird around the house kind of suck
right there are those freshies these
these are freshies so they're not going
to be as bad but
they're still really bad they're still
working with these
these are fresh socks i've had these
since christmas
since christmas this same pair just for
reference for people listening to just
the audio both peter and me
the bottom of our feet about the color
of a sidewalk yeah
your white socks are the color of a
a bottle of sidewalk for secret santa so
maybe i'll take care of that
feel free to bring a bag of your socks
all right
there's a concerted effort i made a few
years back to buy all my socks
from one source and have them all be the
same socks so i never had to match pairs
just every single sock
literally every single sock in my drawer
would be one brand of sock that's clever
i kind of have that but over time
that's fallen apart yeah do you think
there's a brand of sock that's actually
like a good
quality brand where they won't wear out
and get all ready over the years
no that sucks no nobody gets a crap
about your socks lasting
i mean they're materials the materials
break down over time over repeated use
it's called fatigue
that's true yeah i could have like once
that would be my ideal sock is to have
only one pair of socks
that does not get dirty and does not
deteriorate you just keep them on 20
yeah yeah yeah yeah like you know they
have it for shoes right where you can
like put
this like this mater this sort of like
this i don't know it's a spray that you
spray on shoes and they don't get dirty
that's
like liquid flies off oh you're talking
about the the the hydro
repellent the hydrogen hydrophobic
hydrophobic there you go yeah
they like i'm gonna pour ketchup all
over my shirt and it just like runs down
nothing behind people
oh sure yeah our vestiges have that same
waterproof coating we're gonna have like
a
vessy friday where we all wear our vesti
shoes on friday we need to
i don't have any leftovers hey christian
how much can we talk about these new
vessies that we got
they they gave us some corridor edition
vessy shoes
like special corridor laces and they're
not they're going to launch them at some
point but
it was a surprise i walked in uh
christian literally threw a box at my
face
and because i'm a ninja i caught it and
uh i was like yeah new shoes what up
you knew what was inside the box yes so
are we so lame that socks is the best
answer we have for the christmas gift
yeah kind of yeah i just got money
because i like money so much you buy
socks with money
yeah you're right you're right see money
was probably my favorite
christmas present this year i take that
back my wife got me some
new air pods because i had older airpods
but then i lost one
in a store and then just stopped wearing
them so then i stole
the uh the what were the
the raycons that we use here and so then
we shot a whole like
segment about raycon but couldn't use it
because i had left them at home that's
why we couldn't use it
so now i have new headphones so uh we'll
never have to go through that again well
well that's cool i've also got this mask
though i literally
that's the most 20 20 gift ever is
getting a mask for christmas
for christmas yeah i'm trying to make it
through the pandemic without ever having
to have bot masks
oh wow yep you've just been given masks
uh
this is from my neighbors they give me a
box of masks okay that's nice
stylish black mask yeah i have like 80s
did you give one to sam
no because he's wearing he wears a very
similar one
buddies
it was not a christmas present
but i have an oculus quest 2 and that
might as well have been my christmas
present because that was the thing i was
most obsessed with over the christmas
break
christian gave one gave a quest to his
parents i gave a question to my dad
oh well wren has a quest i have a quest
my and my father-in-law
got a quest from his from my
mother-in-law
uh he's he's like 67 years old
and uh on his third song on beats there
was already playing hard
like he gets it that's amazing did wren
you and i logged into population one
last night to play a couple battle
royale games
my dad is online he's been playing for
like two hours it was kind of awkward
because i
i logged in and i was waiting for you to
log in but your dad was online i was
like
uh do i join in with him real quick i
don't know what to do right now
yeah i'm in that situation where it's
like i'm playing video games with my
buddies and my dad
but is it family time or is it friend
time is it you know maybe i guess it's
the same now but
it's like we're shooting at the same
people that's awesome
yeah he was playing pop one yeah no way
cool yeah dude cool dad you got a cool
dad man it's my favorite
game population one is amazing it's such
a good game i'm
yeah it's just fun yeah we have it i
love the climbing and everything
have you been playing the soaring i i
play a little bit i i like pavlov a lot
that loves great my go-to yeah yeah i
think what makes
population one better is the quest
headset
i feel like if you have a chord into
your headset it's just not the best game
for that
yeah because the snap turning is kind of
janky and i don't like turning all the
way around with my chord because yeah
you know it's i still have like phantom
limb with like my chord sense
360 still because i've programmed myself
not to do 360s
yeah so you gotta get out of that man
yeah i find myself i still will use the
turning
and just end up standing there and it's
like i have this whole room i can
utilize i can run around
i say that because i'm currently in the
middle of moving and so over this last
week
uh all of our stuff got moved out and so
i've had an
empty living room so i've had the
biggest play space ever that's amazing
where i can literally like run behind
cover
does it not have trouble like tracking
those white walls no
no no goodness dude i was telling dee
about the quest too and he's like oh man
can you imagine that just like
playing pavlov and jump into a room and
like blah blah blah blah blah blah just
ice everybody turn around and go
i got no strings on me
oh man i still have the old rift rift
i i still feel really bad for you man oh
that's true the rip dust is a good
headset i like that
but it's but you got it like this summer
just a couple months before the
the quest two was announced yeah man and
because they were hard to get you had to
buy it on ebay
at a huge price
it was like 500 something bucks
good games yeah oh i mean look half-life
alex is
like that was okay
i've heard a rumor around the studio
that nico does not like half-life alex
no i like half of alex i just don't
think it's finished playing
finnish okay well you haven't played how
far have you gotten then
about halfway he hasn't made it to jeff
oh my god so you haven't made it
you haven't played the best like levels
in the game basically yeah
i got kind of tired with the room by
room puzzles which kind of felt like
2004 game design i'm sorry
he's more of a 2020 gamer
don't get me wrong it's a great game but
it's just there's actually enough good
games in vr
that i can play the games that are
sucking me in right now i've always been
like a sucker for like
team-based social experience games of
which
population one is the perfect game yeah
true i mean
population one is perhaps the perfect
game well okay
wow well i guess i'm just a loner with
no friends that likes to just hang out
in my own apartment
during quarantine games dude that got me
through quarantine
yeah i know it did it really did yeah it
inspired me so much i
literally modeled my entire video over
it yeah seriously
uh back in the beginning times of covid
i feel like
i'm having deja vu right now didn't we
just talk about literally all of these
things in a previous podcast
well if you haven't seen our other
podcasts just watch this
it's the only one you need what else can
we talk about that
we already talked about i lost my
onewheel today
that's a good one oh yeah all right i'm
gonna tell this story oh yeah you
haven't heard the story so yeah i just
got here
um let's probably start with the text
it's like 9am
everybody's eating their cereal
and the red sends the text please
continue okay i was like hey take it
away
uh so i text uh
the crew guys i think i lost my one
wheel
and i'm in full panic mode right now
because i i go out
to my car to load some boxes into it
because like i was saying i'm in the
middle of moving so every morning
movers came through and took all the big
stuff but we have a few boxes left so
i'm just like over the course of the
week
in the morning load up some boxes after
work i'll go drop them off
at the house and then go home while i
open up my trunk
and the one wheel's not there i was like
that's weird i don't remember taking it
inside last night
where's the one wheel and uh
i realized what exactly what i had done
because you and i yesterday we were
racing each other down the street
remember
so i was definitely on my one wheel when
i left the studio
and you left and i went around the
corner to where i parked on the main
street out there
right and i i pull up to a skid stop
very stylish up on the sidewalk there
had to throw that in naturally of course
and so i got off
and i walked into my car and drove away
literally like walked over got in my
driver's seat
put it into drive and you took off left
you stopped thinking about it
immediately yeah basically brent is so
rich
dude for you that's so surprising
because for me it's like it feels like
it would be like losing a limb
you know because it's like the one wheel
is your life it was worse than that it
felt like i lost like a baby yeah like
like this morning i was literally
crushed i was like because i left it
there on the sidewalk there's
absolutely zero chance it is still there
this morning
yeah and uh after like the panic kind of
subsided a little bit i thought about it
i was like wait a minute
i also went to my house to offload these
boxes where the one wheel on its stand
is in the way
so i think what i did was i took the one
wheel out of
the trunk after so what i'm saying is
that i actually did load it into my car
on on the street out there
and well you hope i hope okay i'll get
to that and so
what i think i did is i actually took
the the one wheel out of my trunk
at my house in my garage put on the
ground to take out the boxes load them
into the house and then when i
got back in it was it's really dark in
that garage so i think i just closed the
trunk and
got in and left i have not checked the
house yet i have not checked the garage
so if i get to there in the and i open
the garage and there's no one wheel
um i'm taking the rest of the year off
you should
it's only five days you need a whole
year of mourning for that to be honest
because that would mean it actually
legitimately is gone but i'm like
i'm fairly certain that's what i had to
have done because the only reason why i
thought that i actually did leave it
there is because i've done that before
like i actually have done that before
where i leave it on the road
and i drive away fortunately the one
time i did that
i remember seeing it and i forget it was
either
the side view mirrors or the rear view
mirrors i remember seeing it being like
oh whose one wheel is that who's just
leaving a woman on the street like a
stupid doofus oh
crap that's me immediately went back and
grabbed it
um so it wasn't that bad but it could
have been worse and so that's why i
think my brain went to there first
rather than remembering that i had gone
to my house my new house as well
and so i guess right after this podcast
i'm going to go to that house and see if
it's there wait so you don't know
i don't know oh ren i know i'm pretty
sure how many miles do you have that
wheel
that one's got uh
four and a half thousand just shy of
four and a half thousand years well yeah
wow and that's like like 4 300. when you
log miles that's just
that's uh specific to the one wheel
yeah so my my first one my v1 that i got
almost five years ago at this point has
four thousand miles as well
okay wow yeah that's crazy and did you
have another xr that you had to get
replaced because like water damage or
something no it was
this one but didn't reset the odometer
okay
it did for a while it's weird because so
it was reset
but it kept both numbers so it kept the
original mileage
so uh being tallied up with the new
mileage and it would just like literally
like flop back and forth it would give
me like
oh 100 miles oh 1500 miles
and then just switch back and forth
between those two until now it just it's
it's the total number
i don't know why my v1 had a weird thing
where it uh it got damaged pretty hard
and it erased
all the memories but i had i have
screenshots of the mileage on it before
then and the mileage after so i've added
those two together
nice huh wow yeah
well you'd have to clock some more miles
on a new one if you don't
oh we could talk about the the riots so
uh we went into town today and i was
riding the onewheel pint because i
don't have my onewheel currently and uh
made it to downtown we're gonna go get
lunch but we saw like literally
several helicopters flying around over
like the capitol building in
uh city hall et cetera and so we decided
to rush over there
um took some videos lots of police
everywhere apparently we just missed
like a big mob
like uh yeah so
that's like three four miles away and my
one wheel died
like the battery ran out of power but it
was still registering as half
full but what that means is that one of
the battery cells is probably bad
yeah so now our pint is needs to be sent
in to be
replaced when christian came picked you
up like a good friend yeah christian i
was like christian i need a favor and he
came and picked me up no complaints
i was very grateful he's over there like
yeah
well and i were eating our hiroshima
specialty
noodle pancakes it was some sort of a
like noodle
pancake thing it's like several layers
you call it like a noodle stack
yeah wow noodle stuff it's like it was
good it's like cabbage and like fried
crispy ramen noodles and like a thin egg
pancakes scallions
meat a nice tasty sauce sounds amazing
yeah apparently it's pretty good yeah
it's like the the go-to street food in
hiroshima
yeah yeah that sounds amazing it's
pretty authentic i should have gone
instead of eating my trader joe's salad
that i had today i mean hey trader joe's
makes good snow is it the
kale and thousand island one it's the uh
one with raisins
it's that freaking raisin one yeah yeah
that's where it's at oh yeah
it's delicious so yeah yeah if y'all
have any thoughts on that
what's your favorite trader joe's salad
but yeah did you guys so you guys saw
like like was i mean
i'm assuming they're just protests and
it was a bunch of you know trump
extremists
hanging out uh by the time we there we
were there there weren't that many of
them it wasn't like a big crowd of
people
there was like 20 of them yeah it was it
was scattered over the cross of
over the course of like a block or two
but mostly it was just
a tremendous number of police officers i
think
more police officers than i saw during
the black lives matter
uh protests earlier this summer well
yeah
yeah that's insane man yeah it's just
crazy we just heard about this today too
so like
you know it's hard to mm-hmm well it's
because it's happening today yeah
all around the country or is it just
here i mean i think it's happening in
l.a because l.a is a big city so
it pulls people out anytime something
happens somewhere else there's going to
be like a little small satellite
version of that happening there's
protests happening at la city hall
yeah and it's and to be fair it's
probably happening that way in many
other big cities across the country
but obviously today the big one is in dc
storm in the capitol building god that's
insane
yeah yeah but nico doesn't want us to
talk about that well
i mean here's the just here's the
philosophy behind that it's
the whole idea that you give power to
something when you give it your
attention and your energy whether you
like that thing or not
yeah you know it's like if you want
someone to be irrelevant
stop talking about them dude
that's the only storm the capital
building
a woman was shot and killed yeah yeah
she was shot
and then in critical condition and then
they just announced that she had died we
don't know anything more about him
was she one of the people storming the
building she was inside the camera
details have been released so i gotcha
all right so i don't want to make any
assumptions about who she was or her
character or anything like that but
you know she was inside the capitol
building so wow
yeah pretty pretty crappy but like is it
is it
if we talk about it is that going to
give them power
as opposed to them giving themselves
power because i feel like a lot of it
like stemmed from the conspiracies
and its own like inner circle anything i
don't like is a conspiracy
and all of this misinformation red hats
you know
yeah i mean circulated i don't know it's
it's challenging it's like
you want to you want to try to do good
right you want to try to
communicate you want to try to
understand people you want to be you
know
the vast majority of people are all the
same you know it's like
differences in opinions and
disagreements come through different
life experiences context having a
different understanding of facts like
all that kind of stuff
you know obviously there's only one set
of facts you know there should be the
truth but
real life is never so simple there's
always nuance and all that kind of stuff
um but you know so like it's always
important to think to talk to people
with understanding
but when it comes to
i don't like talking politics that much
because it's just it's rarely is it
productive
um at least in this kind of situation
like when it's broadcast for
entertainment you know it's like yeah
yeah it's really it turns into a sports
team kind of thing you know we don't
know what the hell we're talking about
yeah yeah it's like true
i read it today that yeah these people
were doing this thing that's how you
take this headline
i'm always cool with like talking about
philosophy because i feel like
philosophy is like the thing that's
apolitical it doesn't identify with the
political party now
whether that leads you to you know
approach how
you know economics or just you know
social justice like that in different
ways
cool whatever you know take your take
the philosophies and apply them to your
life however you want and i'm always
down to talk about philosophies but
politics
is just uh i feel like that's
politics are best discussed in a
situation where actively trying to
engage in
learning from or sharing knowledge with
somebody else
so this question i'm not sure how it
stacks up to what you just said but
how do you guys feel about uh how things
are gonna go down
on january 20th day before my birthday
is it really a pretty good birthday
present yeah no kidding okay wow well
okay i guess my assumption here is that
we might see more
unrest and and yeah in all violence
would be speculation
anyway but like i don't i don't know
maybe
maybe not that's again speculation stuff
it's like i don't know
i would hope that people would be civil
i would hope that people
take the time to critically think about
you know
if they're angry about something you
know i hope they take the time to
critically analyze
yeah where they're getting the news from
you know
that's all you can really hope is that
people just take a step back and just
you know because there's so much just
almost white noise of
posts and information going around yeah
okay okay peter yeah
um but yeah you know what what is what
is right what is wrong i don't know
i mean there is right now
do you want to go there matt yes
yeah this is too mellow let's let's get
fiery let's go
human constructs the universe is a place
driven by physics and math
oh my god do you have a white board you
can just kind of break down the map no
i'm kidding i'm just i'm just going off
the deep end here
um yeah be excellent to each other and
try to treat each other
understanding that's all i'll say with
this podcast yeah anybody listening
please just
please just even if you disagree with
other people please just try to take the
time to talk
and be civil no one's going to change
anybody's minds or help things for the
better
if you're just trying to go at somebody
to make yourself feel right or feel
better
like why have the conversation you're
not you're not helping anybody it's
it turns into a self-indulgent kind of
thing you know
um yeah that's right that's my take on
it
yeah yeah yeah i mean
that's that's what they were doing in
congress is they were trying to have a
civil
debate you know and and i would love to
see a world
where the leaders on
the democratic side the republican side
or whatever other political party might
exist at the time i'd love to see
whether
on both sides they are stand up smart
people
so that the government and the policies
being enacted
is a culmination of the best ideas from
both sides
and people that can speak to everybody's
experiences and everybody's needs
rather than one side being right and one
side being wrong ideally it's one side's
got one perspective the other side is
the other perspective and you're
reaching the best
possible solution by being able to hear
all the sides and come to the best
decision
that's how it's supposed to work yeah
that sounds pretty dang ideal
yeah yeah on the same team at the end of
the day yeah i'm just trying to make it
all work
and you know i think you know the way we
absorb media these days certainly
doesn't help because at this point you
know the news has to compete with
tick-tock you know so it's like
yeah and for that matter tick-tock
itself is most people's
news and you know it gets it gets real
messy because he
everybody has their own truth now
everybody has their own world their own
context which kind of makes sense
there's six billion of us you know we
all have different life experiences and
things we need
um
yeah i get my news from reddit and it's
like that passes through the filter
of the reddit demographic upvoting
things it's not like
every piece of news is brought to the
front page it's just the things that
people pay attention to yeah i mean i
spent a little time reading the news
from ellie times new york times cnn
reddit and like the stuff that gets up
voted there and you very quickly see
just how much of the news it's basically
just
paparazzi magazines just for politics
and how much it was just like you know
this side is for people who don't like
trump so everything about trump's can be
spun a certain way regardless if it's
good or bad
so you know even if there's something
legitimately bad that trump does it's
kind of like a boy who cries wolf
situation you know
yeah vice versa here's a site that you
know praises trump for everything
and it's just kind of the exact same
scenario and like
through all that you get to see like
okay here's the little bit of actual
news that happens each day then here's
the rest of the content that it needs to
be
literally fabricated and manufactured to
get people to read
so what kind of people are reading our
site what do they want to read more of
let's give more of that
and i mean that's how the entire i mean
it's that's media you have to remind
remind yourself that news is a certain
form of media it's supported by
advertising just like everything else
you know it takes critical thought and
active personal energy to
try to actually learn what the actual
situation is
um and that just that takes a lot of
time and people don't have that time
let alone like you can even do anything
about it you know it's like
do the best you can with what you can
control and beyond that
you know you can have an opinion if you
want but
it will yeah it's hard it's just like i
would love to find a new source that
isn't
like actual genuinely isn't biased yeah
that's why i like
this does that exist i don't think it
does that's why you just read multiple
sources yeah
for sure yeah so that's i try to the
reason why i like google news is because
it's an aggregate
of a bunch of uh top news sites you know
l.a times new york times washington post
even fox news and so they'll show you
that so like the news will be distilled
into one category like and it's always
at the top like this is the biggest
breaking news of the day
and then when you click that it actually
loads up all of these different news
sites
uh reporting on that and you see all the
different headlines and the way they
spin that news
from every network is is different wow
um
just know and like word choice and stuff
like that what they want to point out in
the headline
versus what's actually happening and so
like i always feel like i can generally
get a gist of
of kind of what's going on just by at
least broadly seeing that
i if it makes me feel like i'm a little
bit more unbiased when i look at it
that way rather than specifically going
to la times or something like that
sure i don't have a membership too so i
can't
no i think that's that's a really
respectable thing to take the time to
like
you know read things from multiple
sources try to get a general sense of
things
but that being said google news does
also know who i am
they they they do actually have like a
news for you section
it's like here's some news about
pasadena here's some news about tech
that you like and i'm like oh goodness
cool so i don't know how that
counteracts the point i just made about
trying to make things unbiased by
reading a bunch of different
yeah i wonder if that like standard
google news is
like influenced by your algorithm dude i
think so i mean it is but
like certain parts like the personalized
part of google news is absolutely
you know uh but like besides that i i'm
just wondering if like the standard run
in the middle
i was assuming not i was assuming it's a
broad
it might be like hey you're in america
here's american news like hopefully it's
yeah and you can choose world news but
uh
at the top is just us news top top news
yeah
yeah yeah but like these echo chambers
are created on all these sites just
because it's like it's what you want to
hear
you know regurgitate it back to you
based on your opinions and like
that's that's the kind of stuff that
like i want to find a source that
doesn't do that and i mean if it is
google great but
yeah i i just don't i don't even know if
i necessarily trust that but it's very
challenging to do yeah that's for sure
yeah but you're right nico it's just
like try to find
as many sources as you can and you know
try to try to
come to some sort of uh middle ground um
yeah
and be accepting of people and love
people yeah definitely
assume the best in people rather than
the worst and yeah you yourself will
have a happier more stressful life and
that's the other thing too is like
pause and look around you right like if
the news is telling you like things are
so bad there's just so bad right now
and that's totally cool you can
acknowledge that things can be bad
somewhere they might be bad here but
also take a moment
and just look around you does your
neighbor need help
are things okay is the sun shining is
the street falling apart like
you know look around you and absorb that
world and honestly that should be your
priority you know not what's happening
in the news it should be
literally your neighbors your block your
neighborhood your community your city
like
start there and look outwards from there
and like that's your reality
because everything else you know it's
just pictures and words on the newspaper
and yeah it's happening somewhere but
we get so sucked in like to world news
when in reality there's like
nothing we can do about it whereas if we
focus more on our community
that's where we could have an actual
impact yeah the smaller scale yeah sure
yeah
you know whether it's you know whether
it's just like a person helping another
person or it's whether it's politics
like
starting local is definitely like where
you can actually make a difference and
work out from there so hashtag ad google
news
to go back to that they they do have
like you can put in a uh
zip code and so like for the previous
three years i was living in pasadena and
so that that zip code
for there uh it would just give me all
the news for the entire city
and so it was it was kind of cool
sometimes because you'd see like news
and you're like i know that block
or like i know that store and it's like
it really felt like it affected me
personally
um by reading local news and
and google news uh aggregates all that
stuff for you
are you sponsored bro
wait he did not say no the record shows
it has to be in the first 30 seconds of
the video it has to be the first link in
the description
yeah yeah can we make some edits to this
podcast like all of us here
there is a thing like i remember i
actually did a paper on this in college
for my critical internet studies class
which i thought was the
goofiest sounding throwaway class but
i had a project in that class i've told
i think i've talked about this in the
podcast before
there was some value surprisingly um
because it didn't seem like there would
be
um but one of the projects i did was to
see how high on the uh
leaderboards i could get with rock band
every time it sounded as academic as
possible
i played the drums nice uh and i got to
10.
wow on the world leaderboards oh my
goodness
oh the sound of that drumstick hitting
that plastic yeah
my four neighbors oh my poor roommates
sam and ian
man you figured out a way to finagle
yourself into playing video games
and get a grade for it well other people
have played like world of warcraft it's
like a whole like
what's a social interaction like in a
video game you know setting and whether
it's
a leaderboard thing or it's you know
mmos or whatever like
of course it totally seems like a
throwaway thing but now there's like
that was freaking billions of dollars in
these streets so i was like i guess it
wasn't that throw away
the funny thing about like the getting
on the leaderboards for rock bands so to
level up
it was ranked by a level and like the
highest level was like 40 at the time or
something like that
so to level up you had to beat someone
else at or above your level
so once i got to i got to 11
for me to level up i need to catch one
through 10
at some point online and duel them on
the drums
so i played every night for like two or
three hours oh my god
every once in a while one of them would
come through and just it would be like
my heart would beat
my adrenaline dude
oh my god that's a great way to set up a
leaderboard oh my god it was it was so
fun like it was just so intense like
when i got to 11 slot in like that one
night when the guy pops in he's like oh
my god he's level 36.
i'm level 35. let's [ __ ] go
i don't remember the song that we played
or anything but yeah
but you remember the experience like
there's such like you know those babies
first rock songs too and
for a lot of that game like there's that
one weezer song
um i don't remember it but it's just
it's very much like
for four minutes and there's one part
goes
and now if you miss that one note you
lose the entire round so it's like
you're just saying there's like oh gotta
be a machine yeah flawless four minutes
of this and then
that that feels coming up don't think
about too hard or you'll miss your beat
now just stand beat
with that phil and one two and
remember the score multipliers right you
wanted your combo to be up so you're
running out like the 4x multiplier the
whole time
you can't break that drop away from the
box multiplier wow
i'm at a point now playing beat saber
where i only play expert plus with
faster song turned on and disappearing
notes oh nice
kid playing ddr at the movie theater
back in the day
yeah because i'm currently trying to get
into the top 100 on as many songs as i
can
and the only way to get up into the top
like 500 is to
be able to play at the those extra
modifiers which give you bonus points
but it does make it harder but yeah so
it's like i i don't know i feel like i
can relate a little bit to what you're
saying about how it's like
just a lot of just trying to get up to
those top ranks yeah do you sweat when
you play that oh tremendously
that must be that's a great aerobic it's
honestly
uh i for the last like two years my only
workout
has been one wheeling and beat saber
dude that's rad because i love that
video because beat saber gets my heart
going one wheeling is not a good aerobic
activity but it is a good like
toning yeah for your legs uh so you guys
call it beating it like i'm gonna beat
it jenna just like all right have fun
beating it
no absolutely not a lot lately
she got really into it too she's she's
like playing expert and expert plus
songs now too
but she doesn't like going at it as hard
as i do
she doesn't beat it as much as i do
uh you guys should beat it together yeah
okay matt
yeah so yeah beat saber is is not my
favorite game anymore but it's like it's
so
like in my bedrock of of
lore for me at this point that i'm like
i yeah what's your highest rank on a
song
uh for a while there i was i was like 13
on a song
on the psvr uh but that was like over a
year ago and that
rank has since dropped down to like 60.
but on the oculus quest
i i played a song called crab rave yeah
with those uh
and i got an ss score with it i only
missed like three notes with the faster
song and the uh disappearing arrows and
that got me to a 109.
oh geez uh and i think the player base
on oculus is higher because it's it's
not just the quest it's also
desktop oculus anyone using an oculus
account
uh so that was cool and that has since
dropped down to like 130
i think last time that's pretty crazy
actually that
the entire world there's only been 113
runs better than that one
yeah goodness and now it's like you feel
it too like when you feel like you're
just on it and you're hitting notes it's
like you're in the rhythm and
yeah you're just like i can't mess up
you ever beat in your sleep
we're still doing that joke no i'm not
even kidding
it's like my like my girlfriend who runs
a lot will like run in her sleep and so
i'm wondering if you
oh feet in your nose don't call that
i'm not no i don't i don't think i've
ever dreamed about playing beat saber
i'm just like just like
hilarious i played enough half-life alex
that i did dream about
being in vr almost like in like the vr
space
like i felt the headset on and
everything was super looking like this
oh wow
yeah it's like you can dream about
anything but i'm dreaming about a thing
i can literally do in real life and it
makes no difference
you know i have to admit i've never
played boneworks
i've yet i mean i have the game but i uh
i got the game
and then uh because i was borrowing the
the corridor rift s at the
time and this is through all of like
kovid whereas kind of we're going back
and forth between working at home
working in the studio working at home
again
and uh i have a computer i didn't have a
computer that could run
anything like that so then i had to get
back the headset then i had to bring
back the computer and it's like yeah so
once i got a new computer i'm ready to
boot up boneworks and play through the
whole thing
it's great just like a year late it's
it's really fun
parts of it are a bit janky but besides
the jank it's like
a great game they're working on uh
project four
whatever that one's being titled yeah
we'll see
i don't know works either by the way
yeah yeah it's it's basically just like
the promise of
the boneworks physics system but on the
quest oh wow
and i i don't want to say anything more
about it i know a little bit more but
it's not my place to say yeah i'm trying
to figure that out and unreal the
physics-based enemies that you can
interact with okay yeah can we talk
about that real quick
you freaking went off over the last
month you went from being like
what is this thing oh it's called unreal
you're like
actually doing straight up like really
complicated game mechanics
dude and you're like designing them from
scratch and you've got
not designing them from scratch i've
been watching plenty of tutorials but uh
yeah over break i was just hanging at
home at the house to myself i was just
like working on vr games the whole time
it's super fun i have like
physical hands set up so if you put your
hand like against the wall it'll stay
there and not go through the wall
stuff like that you actually have uh
like an amount of force you can press
it's like the bone works thing i've
basically basically been making that
much you basically just did bone work
basically works by myself um
no but yeah i got some guns set up and
stuff next step is getting those enemies
working but i mean it's
i think it's a big reason why you're
here peter is that like uh
you've just you've always been really
good at like really quickly learning
stuff like that
because literally you hadn't even
touched the program like at the
beginning of december
and now like you you probably have
enough of a skill set that you could
probably get hired at a game company
somewhere
well probably doing like really like
low-level stuff but
you know yeah definitely no i i just go
crunch it out in the game company for
you guys a week oh my gosh
but yeah it helps when it's really fun
you know unreal unreal is basically just
blender
and you're making games with it instead
it's the best it's super fun
and i guess that's the big thing is i
feel like there's a huge amount of
crossover between blender and unreal oh
so much because it even looks similar
like the user interface looks similar
yeah it's that dark gray
with like the orange outlines and things
exactly yeah
yeah yeah having that background
definitely helps
like i'm sure any of us like you could
pick up blender i could pick up c4d you
know
it's all the same stuff i've thought
about picking up blender and learning it
i've also thought about picking up
houdini and learning that i think i'd
rather learn houdini
i know and then it's so complicated but
at the same time i feel like
my brain work is a little bit more
adjusted to the direction houdini goes
in rather than like say unreal
i say that not knowing either program
with experience it's my node based
it is node-based nodes yeah lots of
nodes
yeah i don't know i just i i see some of
the stuff that you can do with houdini
and i'm like i want
that i want to be able to do that yeah
but i i feel like i need to learn unreal
instead because i feel like
there's going to be opportunities in the
near future by near future i mean over
the
next one to three years where having
that experience with unreal will be very
handy
yeah like the series that we're gonna
shoot in unreal in like a couple months
yeah just like that
niko how have you been feeling about
starting unreal with your marble game
journey
uh unreal was really cool like it's a
really neat program i'd
peter hooked me up with his uh tutorial
account so i did the marvel tutorial
where i made a marvel roll around in
amazing
oh demi udemy yep which is really cool
it was a great tutorial by the way
yeah um but it's one of those things
it's like boy that's neat and like you
look
over like the little wall that you're
like you're climbing over and you see
that it's just like
5 000 miles like more walls to climb
like oh my god
that's true yeah so i don't know how
deep i'll get into it but i think
as it is with a lot of things in my life
knowing a little bit of it really
because it's really useful for me at
least in terms of communicating with
other people who know a lot more about
it
true and you know i can help them and
they can help me and
make it all it's a make it all a better
world well especially in the role of
like a director
really like your key skill set that is
needed as a director is communication
and knowing more about what you're
talking about is really helpful like
john favor for instance
actually knows a decent amount about
visual effects and that helps him
whenever he's directing because
not only does he know like uh how to
kind of uh perceive what something
should look like and how to set up a
camera to make
a shot happen yeah how to shoot for vfx
but also how to communicate
with the right terminology to the right
people as opposed to being like
fix it in post you know dude john
favreau is
just a legend at this point he is he has
done so he directed elf and iron man
and was in the replacements if you ever
saw that movie
with keanu reeves football team back in
the day he was like this crazy
roided out dude who just like he was
like a bull he saw red and he would just
run for it
because like he started as an actor like
a comedian comedic
actor yeah just crazy yeah he's like i
feel like his approach to star wars is
how
george lucas approached it back in the
day it's very much like
a very modern visual effect technique
that's never been used before
being pioneered to do really unique
looks and enable them to create worlds
which is kind of the whole point yeah um
and
maybe not the most complicated writing
in the world
it's like as freddie once said a simple
story told well
is better than a complicated story that
tried
right that's yeah good point that's kind
of how i feel about
hot take tennant i watched it this is my
third time
yes i know i'm sorry i'm sorry peter i'm
sure you're
okay to be fair i had to watch it three
times before i understood it yeah that's
not a good movie it's just
so good you didn't like it no i didn't
like it okay i sort of
kind of i have yet to see tennant like
okay
and i'm like christians i think you will
see deception is one of my favorite
movies of all time
strap in for all three viewings to
really even understand
with guns no no no
it's so good the problem is i feel like
with a movie you have
you have to at least be able to
understand what's going on to to relate
to the characters
the first time you watch it yeah like if
you have to go back to a movie and
re-watch it
before you can even feel anything for
the characters because it's like
the world is so tied to the emotions of
the characters and
and the the pace of the story and
literally everything about the movie
revolves around these two worlds that
are mirrored basically yeah so like it's
really important that you understand
that world and true they literally in
the first like
scene of the movie or the first couple
of scenes of the movie the first act
right
they're like just don't think about it
remember when the decision was like you
know
you
don't just don't think about it just
feel it feel just feel it don't think
about it just feel it
i feel like that's that's what okay i
also feel like that's christopher nolan
being like
this is the hardest thing in the world
to write give me a break
it's gonna be a fun movie though so just
sit yeah but so i went back and really
after my third viewing of tenet i went
back and watched inception again because
that movie i i remembered like that
that kind of movie when it came out
people were like oh my god it's so
confusing and stuff yeah
it's not that confusing but no it's
actually not and it the way that he like
sets up the world and kind of like shows
how it all works and functions
yeah is really like it's really simple
um even
like i watched it again just thinking
like you know taking a step back and
going like if i were to watch this the
first time would i be able to understand
everything
and you totally can like because all the
elements are in place for you to watch
it
one time and be able to fully understand
it inception has more of that like
nice slow pace and then like really
hectic moments whereas tenant is just
like
yeah it paces things and slowly builds
on them upon
ideas right so it's like it introduces
you to the idea of going into dreams
right
and then it goes hey there's multiple
layers to these dreams right you can go
deeper into dreams you know what'd you
guys think of that world war ii movie he
did what was the name of it
it was like i can see it i felt like it
was beautifully shot
supremely well directed
average story yeah it was like
soldiers want to get off the beach yeah
that's the story you know it's like
yeah and they made tents there's great
action hey but harry styles is in it
what a what a beaut what a beefcake what
a beefcake
yeah i mean it was one of those movies
that i was like i guess i enjoyed it
when i was watching it i thought it was
a little slow but you know it's
christopher nolan
you stick with it uh and i at the end of
it you realize that there's like three
different
time scales going on in the movie that
was confusing i was more confused in
dunkirk than i was in tennant really
okay get out of here
really seriously yes seriously yes and
it's like
i guess i like that i thought that was
cool and i walked out of it going i
don't think i'm ever going to watch that
ever again yeah same
yeah and that's how i feel about it it's
like it was good never going to watch it
again
didn't have anything to say i mean
outside just a normal like you know
be a good person you know like or bad
yeah it didn't really have anything more
it didn't add anything to the
conversation
yeah like saving private ryan added
something to this conversation of world
war ii
right um i think that's a bit of the the
issue that films are facing right now
i mean every medium has to evolve it's
like i think we hit a point like there's
a lot of filmmaking that's happening in
the united states you know
in the black and white era which
informed what happened when we hit the
color era and the color
the style of filmmaking when we hit
color and sound was
so different the stories they were
telling were so different you have these
long sprawling westerns you have these
really deep like romances you have these
studies on human life and because it's
all fascinating it's a window to
something
and then as we hit like the late 70s
moving to the 80s people like boy that
stuff's really boring and slow now can
you get a little bit faster and you
start getting like
your total recalls and you're like you
start getting into all these like great
80s action films you know predator
commander all that kind of stuff
commander commander and then like in the
90s you hit
the perfection of that formula it's like
movies are so tight i was like oh my god
there's so many cuts per second now you
know it's like that conversation's
happening
and then after the 90s independence day
you hit
franchises right because then they start
to struggle it's like well new movies
aren't quite doing it so there was like
yeah i've been seeing it for 30 years
like give me something new it's like
well we can do basically really
expensive tv shows aka movie franchises
and now we're hitting the point where
it's just like
even spending a billion dollars on a
movie and having
one cut for every single frame but
that's still not enough to make you give
a [ __ ]
about watching a movie and i think
that's like where dunkirk comes into
play it's like he watched that it's like
this is like so many talented people
made this but like
it's just like it's assassin's creed
eight at that point it's like cool like
if you love assassin's creed you love
the movie but
there's like nothing to write home about
it's just assassin's creed eight
assassins creed nine's gonna come out
next year you know it's like
yeah true so i don't you know
filmmaking's in a weird spot but it's
always gonna be a weird spot
yeah i mean i do admire tenet for trying
something actually new where there's one
scene
that you see all the way through
forwards and then you see it again
all the way backwards with a new context
and you're like whoa
okay that's cool okay sure that sounds
great on paper
but like just [ __ ] that they don't
explain in that movie like straight up
and i don't want to like spoil anything
because not a lot yeah because it's not
on blue right now i can go watch this
tonight if i wanted to yeah but you know
it's not
unless you want to steal it it's easily
accessible you got to pay like 20 bucks
for it right now
oh really yeah well that sucks so yes
so i've actually been reading up on on
soul because uh
the director uh pete doctor uh also
directed up
which i'm currently making a video about
and he also directed monsters inc
and so oh my gosh and uh inside out
yeah inside out monsters inc up and
seoul although now he's he's like
the president of pixar oh really he's he
kind of stepped into that role after uh
lasseter john lasseter had to step down
accusations of
uh misconduct was it john lester or
andrew stanton
john lasseter because he was like not i
don't know if the ceo is the right word
to say but like he was like the
president of pixar he was like the
top guy top dude and now pete doctor is
that top dude so people are saying that
like uh
soul is his last movie oh wow cause he's
gonna make
he's gonna be more of like a creative
director across the board
they've got and he's like pixar has done
a lot of sequels over the last 10 years
we're gonna try to dial that back a
little bit and start having more new
original stories and whatnot but he also
was like but there's still going to be
some sequel stern in there because they
pay the bills really well
yeah i mean hey they want to make a toy
story 5. like toy story 4 was so
good like make as many sequels as you
want guys yeah like toy story 4 was my
favorite toy story which
i was very surprised to realize after
finishing i was like wow that was good
they clearly go back to those worlds
with love and with the intent of telling
a new story not with the intent of
making more money
i'm sure they have to make more money
and that's why they do them to a certain
extent but like
unless you're talking about cars yes
yeah well we don't talk about cars
we don't talk about cars here seoul was
one of the
the souls great yeah as far as the pixar
movie
goes it reminded me of like how what
what i loved about ratatouille like it
went all the way back to there because
that's one of my favorite pixar movies
brad bird is just and then like
after that it just got to a point where
i was like okay it's kind of pixar doing
a pixar thing
yeah i felt that you know what i mean
and then soul came out and i was like oh
that's got
that's got the soul back
yeah how they how they visualize music
and stuff is a similar way to how they
visualize
taste and like how you combine you know
tastes and show that how do you show
something that is a
another sensory uh how do you convey
that visually uh and it's so creative
yeah
they do that you know what you're saying
about like how a picture is in the pixar
thing like
that's how i felt like yeah coco came
out like there's a guy yeah yeah
i think i watched that was disney not
pixar there was pixel there was a pixel
spectacular it was a pixar drawing oh i
was thinking of moana sorry yeah but
then i just didn't feel oh my god
pictures just doing the pixar's doing
the pixar thing and they're so good at
it
please keep doing the pixar things
yeah exactly you know they have a name
for that one moment in the movie
where everybody cries i forget what it's
called but they have a name for it the
pixar thing
yeah i would love to see them do
the club into like doing like uh you
know batman the dark knight animated
series thing like
go and do something that's like it's
still cartoon but like get intense with
it
you know get a little dark with it yeah
i watched that when i was a kid oh so
good
i mean do you remember the episode where
everybody dies in the beginning no
yes yeah there's an episode of the
batman batman animated series which by
the way one of the things that made that
show unique in terms of its animation
style
is that they would start with all the
backgrounds painted black and then paint
on top of
don't ask me how i know that um how do
you know that but there's an episode
that begins
with uh nightwing uh
like in batman like racing to the bat
cave while the police are chasing them
like gunning them down
and i think nightwing gets killed whoa
um
and uh batgirl gets killed and like
batman's cave is found out by the cops
like his
identity is exposed and like this is
like world collapses and it turns out
of course that it's uh the mad hatter
[ __ ] with him
you know like having him live out his
worst fears oh my goodness
oh so it's just a dream it was just a
dream that was the whole idea but it was
it was asking the question of
if something happened to batgirl how
would commissioner gordon feel about it
in other words it wasn't even really
about batman it's like interesting does
the decisions of
i don't remember her name the
character's name was her
i can't remember that girl that girl
it's like
at what point do her decision and
hathaway um apply to her
versus like how much does he have to
think about other people when she puts
herself out there into a dangerous
situation
if she gets herself killed and you know
gordon
you know is now distraught like has she
wronged him by putting herself into the
situation
yeah and they come to it he's like it's
your life it's your decisions i'll
support you i would be sad if anything
ever happened to you but i would never
blame you for it you know
wow it's like a really good like wow
what a good message what a weird
exploration of a small part of like
being human that we don't really get to
see
black and white kind of narrative yeah
barbara gordon
yeah but yeah it was uh
i'd love to see pixar kind of take just
a little step into that
kind of world for a minute and just do
one piece that's meant
feeling more dark i mean that's it's all
gonna be really cheap i mean yeah they
have a very strong brand
backed by 15 billion dollars it's like
you can't really
you can't really steer that ship too
much off course you're right and if they
if they stop doing their pixar thing
then who would do the pixar thing
sure yeah someone's got a dreamworks oh
my gosh
posters of animals going like this it's
almost how to train your dragon 12.
well that'll have a pixar moment
i went to see how to train your dragon 3
and in the i'm already crying and in the
end scene um it was like really
emotional
when he like with it's like flashes
forward to the future he's with his kids
and he goes back to where he like uh not
abandoned where him and
uh the dragon parted ways and he like
reunites with the dragon and it's this
whole emotional scene where they're
flying through the sky
and i was like sobbing in this movie
theater next to two little girls who
were like completely fine
and i was just like you girls don't
understand the nuances of scene
the technique used in that is pretty
incredible i mean it's kind of some of
the stuff they did in spider-verse right
yeah
or maybe spider-verse did it after i
don't i mean it's basically it's 3d
animation
built to look like it's disney style 2d
animation sure but everything's just
super painterly it looks great moves
great story's good edited amazingly
yeah good story emotional well so it's
the story of how the
mythos of santa claus came to be oh and
it's just the whole time you're like
these children
they need better lives he's making them
happy
yeah it sounds great did they i don't
know how much you know about the
technique of what they
they did with this but did they like
blend uh 2d
animation as well i actually watched a
video on how they did it they
came up with some special algorithms
it's a shading tool
yeah a shading tool they draw 2d it's
it's a 2d animated film but then they
have the computer
look at it and add shading and [ __ ]
yeah they put the dots on them and then
just tell it to tell a computer do it
you do it
because it was able to recognize poses
and stuff like that and with the
direction of light and so i was able to
kind of recognize how to shade a drawing
to make it a little bit more like 3d
wild huh wait was that ai based i'm not
sure i i think i saw the same video you
did
i'm sure and i think it's been just long
enough that i don't recall any details
just watch the video if you want actual
information about that
or watch the vfx rs react i think yeah
we might do with it we would do it at
some point before the question is is
that a vfx arts react or an animator's
reaction
it's not about how it moves about how it
looks animators react i can't be on it
yeah someday someday maybe no i could be
on animators react there's no reason why
i can't
are you handing me the last one briefly
no that's the effects react nevermind
that's the rambo scene yeah
we use key frames now it's because you
and
uh clint are way more animator uh um
aware than i am i think but in terms of
at least like
drawing you guys are way better artistic
drawers than i am thanks
but uh i don't know if if animators
react becomes a bigger thing and it
starts really diving more into like
um you know like more animated like
pixar style thing rather than like
old-school 2d drawings
i'd like to be a part of batman would be
a great thing to react yeah
yeah it would yeah yeah are you talking
about the animation
2021
i don't know if you goals could hear
christian talking there in the back but
he's guiding us into the final five
minutes of this podcast
thank you our spiritual guidance finally
i can fight matt for not liking
it yeah i think i think you want to go
into the back room oh yeah
the dump by the dumpsters thing yeah i
think before we
talked about 2021 i just want to say
that like in the corridor rhythm of the
year for
for all you listeners out there we
we basically end the year around the new
year's christmas time and there's
actually a period of time where about
two to three weeks where
the doors are shut in the studio and
it's quiet and that's led to us
having a rhythm here at the company
which is very much a you know january is
kind of where we
set out new goals we have a new pace for
ourselves we take some time to
experiment
february to march we start speeding up
and then we hit the spring and usually
we bust out a bunch of projects in the
spring
and as that kind of finishes there's
like a breath where things get quiet
again for a second as we jump into the
summer
then we hit the summer hard and we hit
the fall hard and the fall is actually
the busy season for youtube because
there's a lot of ad spending going on
with black friday and christmas and all
kind of stuff
uh and it all winds down right at the
end of the year we all take a break we
recharge our batteries and come back so
that's that's the rhythm
you know of this company and it's boom
the top 20
20 21 and the starting manifested itself
in videos back in like 2017
2018 because it's like we start off the
year with that sort of mentality and so
we would make an announcement video
talking about all right
we're doing things differently this year
and
and people reacted negatively to that
because they're like i just wanted to be
the way it was
without considering like how we as
artists need to kind of
evolve and so anytime they didn't like
anything
they would pin that on oh it's because
they're doing things differently this
year
and so then after that we just stopped
saying we're doing anything different
and people have not had that thing to
pin their complaints on
content now they're just like all you
guys ever make is vfx artists react it's
the only thing you make and i miss the
old days when you made more stuff
and and i actually had this exact
conversation with my with my cousin
who was not that comfortable he was just
like all i mean i it's cool i mean it's
cool that you guys get guests and all
that stuff
and brings in money uh i i can totally
see why that's all you guys do with
these days i'm just like
we do so much more than that and it's
because uh it's the algorithm
yeah if it only serves viewers the
effects artists react and maybe
occasionally a new video
that's not that and so it kind of
especially if they're not really
clicking on those videos anymore they
kind of are just left with this
impression that that's all we put out
whereas in reality they're just not
getting served to the extra videos
that we're making even if they're
subscribers that is true my algorithm is
like
perfectly tailored to a corridor fan
because i was a corridor fan for years
before i worked here
and there's every single youtube page
there will be a react video really like
in the recommendations oh yeah every
single one yeah wow
yeah yeah same right yeah yeah
absolutely would you guys say
uh that the content that we put out
right now plus vfx artists react is the
same amount of content that we were
putting out
it's more more way more okay so yeah
that's what i'd say plus vfx rs react so
you're putting out the same amount of
content
plus vfx artists react yeah right so
it's been the same amount
of of like extra it's like if you go
back to like 2016 to 2018 we were
putting out a video every other day that
was like the
every other day thing so it's like if
you count the number of videos we put
out way more videos back then but those
were like
two to five minutes long like you go
back and look at the first season of
vlogs it was like
literally not a single one was over five
minutes oh wow and and now it's like
twice a week we're putting out 15 minute
videos yeah yeah
goodness i think we just need to make a
push at the top of this year i mean we
should always be doing this but we
should really make a push to
be trying to push the vfx autos react
audience to see the other videos we do
which we did for a little bit with like
when we lit clint on fire it was a great
example like there's a lot of people
that got to see that the vfx rs react
and there's such like an importing of
like people going wow these videos are
so great you guys do such cool stuff
and like i think we need to battle the
algorithm again and like
once again start pushing people to like
hey we did this cool video check out
this video watching this video like just
letting people know that those other
videos exist and
to start off the year we have an idea
i'm not going to tell you much about it
other than two words
luke skywalker likewise
yeah and people already know exactly
what the video is getting yeah yeah yeah
there's two videos the vfx arts react in
a different video
yeah dude uh dean spoiled the end of
mandalorian for me
oh that's the last episode
are you talking about when dumbledore
killed snape yes yes i'm not gonna
obviously i'm not gonna say what the
spoiler is but we were playing halo
online and he just like he gave him the
most like
obvious like oh no i can't what the
thing was
i can't believe it looked like that was
close yes
like i didn't expect that from dean
though i thought he feels better than
that
man i hate it when people just drop i
know he just like dropped a ball on me
and that that's of course that's all i'm
thinking about in the episode too now
it's like oh great this is gonna happen
i'm gonna wait
i'm glad i didn't spoil that attack on
titan thing for you yeah
yeah that you're able to figure that out
watching and trying to figure out who
that was
because netflix doesn't have the
autoplay trailer and so i just see the
still from it and i'm like well i don't
know what it is even though i hate the
autoplay trailer feature
it definitely works oh yeah what
streaming services is on hulu hulu okay
yeah
cool that's cool one more time everybody
watch attack and titles it's so good to
be cool if
lost actually wrapped up all those crazy
ideas into like a real like
imagine a world where somebody goes out
like jj abrams they write the craziest
kookiest story with all these crazy
story threads and you're like boy i
wonder how this is all gonna come
together that would be
fascinating and amazing imagine a world
where that happens and it's fascinating
and amazing
that's attack on titan yeah that's
awesome i can't wait
so the episodes are coming out weekly
except for this past week where they
decided to wait a week when it was gonna
be the big episode
okay anyway and so it's like between
episodes three and four i watched the
entirety of season three
again it was like i just i watched all
of it again just because i needed more
of attack on titan in my life and
that show moves man it's just so easy to
watch yeah i think the main reason why
we watched it is because
they had the dubbed version of season
three out and so that's what i watched
okay i think it's his first time is
season two is not that great season two
is good
you you made me think that season two
was bad and i watched and i was like
season two was amazing
well i guess you know well season one
was still better season one came out in
2012.
that was a long time nuts that's so long
ago and there was seven
years before they came out with season
two oh my goodness wow
uh in this season she was like okay and
then they came out season three he was
like ooh baby
and like season three starts a little
like it's not bad it just starts a
little quiet just a little bit more
local it's not about like the yeah the
titans anymore it's about like
politics yeah exactly
you're like oh my god yeah it's so good
it was kind of great though to have that
second season be kind of political
just because it you got so much more
immersed in the world and set you up for
season three so yeah so
so well yeah anyways it's been just a
really long hashtag ad for an
attack on titan sorry they didn't
sponsor this video
dude i'll do a hashtag ad for attack on
titan for free yeah
we just did we just did and
hulu got your collateral damage lucky
you guys
uh but yeah dude the worst spoiler ever
was not worth spoiler ever but like
the one that bugged me the most was when
halo 2 came out i'm in my computer
science class
it's like this is the small like four
person thing that guys and they're like
oh man
he'll too i got it with me right now i
can't wait to get home he plays like yo
yeah man
i just played this morning ooh no
spoilers like yeah all right no spoilers
boy is it crazy he plays uh an elite in
the second level
a spoiler my man he's like well that's a
spoiler it's like yeah
especially because bungie tried so hard
to keep that a secret it was never in
any of their promotional material they
never talked about it
they never had any sort of like
reference to the fact that you'd be
playing as an elite let alone like the
top elite
yeah uh spoilers for halo 2 by the way
dude i love when companies are creative
with their advertising like that
you know not giving things away in the
advertising having trailers structured
so that it's not just the plot of the
movie in miniature form
man so in 2021 i'm looking forward to uh
halo infinite no i don't know
i don't think i'm gonna buy an xbox no
i'm still going to play halo
infinite because it'll be available on
pc yeah i think microsoft at this point
is like why are we putting a computer
under people's tvs
why are we making xboxes no and that's
that i think they actually legitimately
are going that direction because they're
they're starting to focus on xbox games
pass or whatever yeah and it's like you
just have access to all of their games
now
and you can just because you can play it
on that the quest
you can play xbox games like halo on the
quest by like literally like
i don't know if you have to sideload
stuff or if you just go to like a url
and you can literally just stream
playing stuff to your headset
is it like theater mode something like
that maybe i'm not exactly sure i i
didn't actually try it
but yeah so i i'm that makes me feel
better because i missed out on halo 5
because i didn't ever have an xbox one
and so i played it on my dad's xbox one
and i was like okay that was a fun game
i guess it was okay
and then of course we all go back to
halo 3. still play those games halo 3
halo reach halo 2.
yeah halo reach is really just like the
essence of all the
early halos but yeah yeah i agree i i
find it frustrating going back to
something like halo 2 or halo 3 because
they don't have sprinting
you know it's like i've gotten so used
to sprinting as a mechanic being able to
just get around a map quickly and it's
like oh wow i feel like i'm running
through molasses
yeah yeah so 2021
i'm gonna wrap this up here okay i gotta
get home soon
um oh yeah yeah but 2021 i think what
you can look forward to us
forward to from us is i think we'll be a
lot more focused
uh on what we have this year and trying
to make it as good as it can be we'll be
a little less focused on growing this
year and a little more focused now
on what we have like putting our time
and energy into elevating that like
this year i want to realize that you
know with all this crazy tech that we
have
it's only worth something if we can tell
stories with it so i want to make sure
that we are telling stories that we're
writing that we're directing that we're
creating um and i think a lot of my
intentions gonna be there
on the technical side of things i think
a lot of my attention this year is going
to go towards
uh deep learning and using that for uh
for visuals and for creators and that
kind of stuff whether it's for visual
effects
or crazy you know script ideas from an
ai or you know
music ideas or whatever it is i think
there's a lot of potential there i would
love to
just take the crazy experiments that are
coming out and be able to do fun
experiments and put those on the
corridor crew channel you know not go on
i'm not gonna go out and try to make a
movie with this crazy stuff
but rather it's like how can i play with
this and what's something cool we can do
now as creators
like you know here's your your word of
the day you know write a short story
using that word this is the same thing
for visual effects artists like
here's our here's our self-aware
computer of the day
what kind of crazy images can you get it
to generate you know
well it's because we kind of identified
a bit of a niche that's not being filled
at all where it's like there's a cro
there's a difference between like
computer scientists and visual effects
artists
but the computer scientists are coming
up with the cool tools and they have
their examples and like their two minute
papers and whatnot and it's like
it or you know two minute papers is
looking at their stuff
uh but it's like all of the cool
examples and it's like oh that's pretty
sweet but they're being made by
scientists
not artists mm-hmm and so it's nice to
say that scientists can't be artistic
they're not they're not applying it in
the same sort of way
a uh like we would yeah yeah and i think
that's just a natural thing of
you know most people don't get the
opportunity just to try a bunch of
different stuff all the time for their
job
yeah you have to be good at one thing
that means like doing that every day and
doing it
really well and becoming an expert in
that one thing so somebody who is a
machine learning expert to the point
where they can craft an ai out of
scratch
probably also hasn't put in the five
years of learning how to do like
compositing and run after effects and
premiere and
all that kind of stuff so there's yeah
there's not a whole lot of overlap there
yeah and a huge barrier to entry for
using a lot of that
like experimental software stuff is like
learning how to use
python or coding and stuff like that
linux i'm excited to get into that
yeah and i know you walked us uh both
peter and i yesterday through
some beginner python stuff and thank you
by the way it's like that's what you
have to know
to use these new tools that two minute
papers are talking about it's like oh
man i can't wait till i get my hands on
that
in two years when someone finally is
like all right fine i'll put a gui on
this
and like make it a exe file that you can
load up and use but it's like
you know if you have to be like really
uh into
wanting to use this tool to be able to
break through the barrier of learning
how to use just it's like
raw code the other big thing for 2021 is
the website
oh the website is like revolutionizing
what we can do for all of you guys the
content we make
you know this is the whole algorithm
that we got to think about when we're
making stuff on
corridor the corridor channel not i mean
we still think about in the corridor
crew but it also just so happens that
what we want to make in the quarter crew
is also what people like to watch
and so that just is a great pairing and
not to say that the corridor channel
doesn't
we're not making things people want to
watch but like youtube is not the
the place for you to go and do like a
very focused like 20 minute narrative or
something like that you know where it's
like
i'm gonna do a cool badass sci-fi action
series it's like
awesome don't put it on youtube because
you're not somebody can show you how to
put cool lipstick on
and get way more views than you will you
know it's like it's not the right spot
and just i thought it's not the right
money you know it's like you need to be
able to fund this stuff with people who
are passionate about watching it
and youtube is a little bit more about
the passive kind of come in watch a
video go on watch another video kind of
thing
and a little less of like here's an
artist that's worked on creating this
piece and i can't wait to check it out
and i'm
gonna invest my time and my emotions
into watching this really cool thing you
know
but you get that with now with like
patreon and other places where you can
like support people's
endeavors and with the website we're
seeing finally seeing this opportunity
now
thanks to everybody who subscribed that
we can go out there we can start making
these pieces not they're not you know
multi-million dollar projects
at all you know we're not at that level
yet but we can go out and we can
actually like hey this
this short film the story i do that we
wanted to do
we can you know we've always talked
about how we can make low budget stuff
look good but we have
a budget it's a low budget but we have a
budget let's go out there and do it
screw it let's just go and do it i don't
have to answer to anybody now just
except for the people who are watching
it either they like it or they don't
you know yeah dude yeah it's super
exciting like
you know i guess i can say it because
you know whatever i'm
here at corridor but like i want to i
want to try to get tether launched this
year finally you know i've always wanted
another tether thing so it's like a
[ __ ] tether thing
let's do it i don't need anybody else's
permission anymore no
like it's gonna be a low budget tether
but that's cool like i got a million
ideas in that world and like
the other thing this is what snoop dogg
told me
and he passed the wisdom on to me oh my
god
which is it's not about spending your
time making one
magnificent thing it's about enjoying
the process of doing it
every day and just being good at doing
it every day
and so when it comes to tether it's not
about at this point it's not about
making the one perfect story
it's like if i if we only have the
resources to do three 10-minute episodes
and they're just small stories in the
woods you know in this world
go out and do it enjoy it do the process
finish it get it out there
move on to the next one and just enjoy
the process of doing it every day thanks
tupac thanks snoop dogg i appreciate the
wisdom
journey before destination exactly so it
makes things a lot less intimidating
you're like oh this is a huge project
like it's not a huge project just
day by day just enjoy doing it work out
for two weeks and be done if
that's all you got you know it's like
just do it you know don't don't put too
much weight on your shoulders that's
something
good advice yeah 2021's gonna be
exciting the website's gonna be awesome
if you're listening and you haven't
subscribed consider subscribing we
already have the crew cuts up there
which is amazing
yeah oh yeah i'm looking forward to the
episode that's probably out by now by
the time you guys are listening to this
about the little uh
little the little ppd the pee babies oh
i love them
i saw them pop up like these guys are so
this is like a miyazaki movie
yeah dude i went on a whole freaking
investigation yeah
and you'll find these peak creatures
that that watch us pee
also i've been watching carmichael's
early cuts of functional filmmaking
it's really slick he's been doing an
amazing job i'm so excited to see it i'm
excited to watch it just all the way
through dude i had a great time
like man this is like it should be work
to me but i'm like i'm here i want my
popcorn
like turn the lights down get
comfortable on the couch and like dig in
nice
so yeah it's really cool um so everybody
who subscribed you're enabling all this
thank you so much if you're not
subscribed you know you don't want to
totally get it but if you've been
thinking about it we've got a whole
bunch of stuff there already and like
functional filmmaking is dropping
i think in just a matter of a few weeks
wow so great
yeah very exciting that's going to be
spread those producer points and gree
green light all these new projects
coming up dude we got them and pee pees
the pee babies
all right guys well uh i hope i hope
jake's dog's okay
oh my goodness we'll see what happens um
but even so uh pour one out for bones
pulling out for bones
little bones yeah thank you everybody
for listening you can probably see bones
in the behind the scenes to tactical
too yes okay actually probably he's a
little white dog about this big
very fragile scoots around like like
wheelies
um but yeah thanks so much for listening
everybody uh it's a pleasure being back
here looking
really exciting uh i can't talk anymore
i've been looking forward to showing you
all the cool stuff we're gonna do with
this year
peace and love